The answer is that it is correct when it returns.
All the values it builds up are correct, but unfortunately it doesn't always return.
Let's try to figure out why.
In think about this, we want to think about recursive patterns.
Let's look at the pattern x+.
We've definec x+ as being the sequence of x followed by x.
And now for most instances of x that's not a problem.
If we had plus(lit('a')), it not going to be a problem.
That's going to generate a, aa, aaa, and so on.
But consider this--let's define a equals lit('a'), pat equals plus(opt('a')).
Now, this should be the same. This should also generate a, aa, aaa.
The way we can see that is we have a plus so that generates any number of these.
If we pick a once, we get this. It we pick a twice we get this. If we pick a three times we get this.
But the problem is there's all these other choices in between.
Opt(a) means we we can either be picking a or the empty string.
As we go through the loop for plus, we could pick empty string, empty string, empty string.
We could pick empty string an infinite number of times.
Even though our N is finite--
at some point we're going to ask for pattern of some N--
let's say the set --we won't have a problem with having an infinite number of a's,
but we will have a problem of choosing from the opt(a) the empty part.
If an infinite number of times we choose the empty string rather than choosing a,
then we're never going to get past three as the highest value.
We're going to keep going forever.
That's the problem. We've got to somehow say I don't want to keep choosing the empty string.
I want to make progress and choose something each time through.
So how can we make sure that happens?